[Music]
on this Wednesday night a new contender
in the conservative leadership race
Peter MacKay jumps in to take over from
Andrew Shearer he has been planning for
this for quite some time who else is in
who is a maybe and what strings are
former leaders Stephen Harper pulling
behind the scenes Global News exclusive
astonishing documents reveal evidence of
sexual slavery child abuse and
corruption within DC casinos cold and
crippling the Vancouver area gets
slapped with a major snowstorm and
surprised what happened when Megan
dropped by a Women's Center plus when
life is like a box of chocolates this
country has given me an opportunity
sweet dreams come true for a Syrian
refugee
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the future of the federal
Conservative Party a high-profile
contender has entered the race to become
the next leader Nova Scotia's Peter
MacKay kept his announcement brief just
four words on Twitter I'm in stay tuned
McKay a lawyer and former federal
cabinet minister isn't expected to be
the only one in the running but who else
is in depends in part on who is not the
biggest question is around Ronna Ambrose
who served as interim leader before
Andrew Shearer took over she's widely
considered to be unbeatable if she runs
Michael Couture is in Ottawa tonight
Mike tell us what we know and what we
don't know well Donna a number of
conservatives have dipped their toes in
the pool but you'd have to consider this
announcement as a huge splash now also
making waves to the people in the make a
camp and they include campaign
organizers who helped the maxim Bernays
leadership bid and Doug Ford's election
in Ontario now the people aren't
household names but they do carry weight
in conservative circles and are a clear
indication that McKay is in it to win it
sources are telling global news that
former Progressive Conservative leader
and former Premier of Quebec Jean Shetty
is still considering a run at the top
job but today at least one conservative
strategist says McKay has the early
advantage look there's always a lot of
expectations when a candidate announces
but how they run their campaign can they
catch fire can they catch imagination
beyond I simply name recognition that
will be what the Conservatives are
looking for over the next five six
months and Donna as you mentioned one
wild card in all of this is Juana
Ambrose there have been reports that the
former interim leader is not running but
a source close to her tells us Ambrose
simply hasn't made up her mind just yet
and Mike there's some news today about
former prime minister stephen harper who
still heavily involved in the party
behind the scenes he's resigned from the
board that fund raises for the party why
well done' one conservative source has
told us that harper was already planning
to leave the conservative fund well
before the fall election we do know that
he was unhappy when we broke that story
that the fund was paying for the tuition
for some of Andrews children
here's the significance of all of this
now that he's left the fund Harper will
be free to get involved in the
leadership race if he wants and as
someone who continues to have a great
deal of influence within the
Conservative Party Harper may just want
to help shape the leadership of the
future Donna all right Mike look at or
in Ottawa shanks some stunning
revelations tonight from a global news
investigation in BC a special RCMP unit
looking into illegal gaming discovered
all kinds of evidence of illegal
activity involving organized crime and
money laundering even allegations women
with gambling debts were forced to be
sex workers instead of taking that
evidence further the special police unit
was deemed ineffective and was disbanded
after extensive Freedom of Information
requests Global News obtained a report
that was written before the unit was
shut down and as john hua explains it
contains a catalogue of explosive
allegations that experts believe were
ignored one individual has been charged
in regards to her homicide murder forced
prostitution even child kidnapping as
police investigators connected the
criminal dots many led them to BC
casinos we need to have questions
answered how far did this go the list of
horrifying criminal allegations all
documented in a January 2009 police
report obtained by global news this goes
further than a public inquiry into money
laundering I'm sorry this is this is
very very serious the report was written
by the BCE RCMP s anti illegal gambling
unit I get the purpose to push the
provincial government for more resources
and are reached beyond underground
gaming houses be seized Solicitor
General at the time rich Coleman came to
another conclusion soon after shutting
down I get for being ineffective the
provinces most senior law enforcement
officer not only turned a blind eye to
this report but immediately actively
shut down the policing unit that was
brain
this to his attention one of the most
concerning allegations in this report
that someone connected to Asian
organized crime was allowed to buy into
a BC casino it also alleges that the
regulatory investigator knew about these
connections and still let the deal go
through rich Coleman refused to be
interviewed only providing a statement
as Minister I carried out my fiduciary
and legal duties and to insinuate
otherwise would be incorrect you find
out that nothing has been done until
maybe a couple years ago when all of
this information was brought up publicly
the report also outlines outrageous
examples of possible casino
money-laundering red flagged about a
decade before the problem hit its peak
in this province one subject buying four
point eight million dollars in casino
chips over five years
another purchasing nearly 3.3 million in
chips in just one year you have to
question what actions did regulators
police politicians take former Crown
prosecutor sandy Guerra sino says this
report kills any notion government
naively thought money-laundering was a
victimless crime and mr. Coleman kept
saying oh nothing nothing to see here
that report is absolutely is the nail in
the coffin on any argument that he
didn't know Coleman would eventually
replace I get with another task force
but not until April of 2016
leaving many to wonder what horrific
crimes were committed with no one
connecting the dots john wobble news the
investigative reporter who broke this
story four years ago and continues to
dig into it as global Sam Cooper Sam
joins me from Ottawa this RCMP report
contains stunning allegations and the BC
government was aware of them a decade
ago have there been any repercussions
for anyone involved no Donna there
really hasn't since this 2009 report the
money-laundering only got worse
there's been no accountability from the
government the casino operators the
criminal gains there's been no reckoning
for the ones involved directly in the
money laundering
but we have a money-laundering inquiry
coming up this year in BC its mandate is
to probe whether corruption enable this
scandal to occur and what we've just
revealed it will have to be part of that
inquiries questioning certainly lots of
questions Sam Cooper in Ottawa thanks
thank you a moment of silence swept over
several Canadian universities today in
honor of the 176 lives lost when two
Iranian missiles shot down flight 752 it
was one week ago that families across
this country heard the devastating news
57 of those who died or Canadian
citizens many of them were teachers or
students at universities across the
country and it ottawa's Carleton
University today among those who paid
tribute was a 13 year old his father a
graduate from Carleton was on board the
plane he was amazing and we loved each
other I still can't believe it
I feel like I'm dreaming but I know that
if I was dreaming and that if he woke me
up he'd tell me that it's gonna be okay
the families still deserve so many
answers and need to be able to bring the
bodies of their loved ones home as
Redmond Shannon explains that is going
to take some time and could be
complicated remembering the victims of
flight 752 this memorial on the streets
of Tehran also includes a photo of Qasem
Soleimani the commander killed by a u.s.
airstrike five days before an Iranian
missile downed the passenger jet the
bodies of all 57 Canadians killed remain
in Iran and there are concerns some
victims may not be repatriated to Canada
as Iran does not recognize dual
citizenship this video is believed to be
the mother of a victim pleading for help
from the Canadian government a Canadian
is a Canadian is a Canadian and they are
entitled to all the rights that Canadian
citizens have and we will do our utmost
to make sure that those rights are
accorded to them a meeting in the UK on
Thursday is
designed to coordinate international
efforts on repatriation compensation and
accountability the president rouhani has
made some comments to the effect that
they want to cooperate but of course the
question on everybody's mind is will
they deliver on that promise even the
Iranian government is now acknowledging
it is facing growing anger from its own
people after admitting its missiles shut
down the jet
people make mistakes unforgivable
mistakes but it happened in the time of
the crisis we need to make sure that
these crises will be prevented on the
defensive iran's Foreign Minister says
meanwhile the Iran nuclear deal is not
dead yet this Iranian journalist told
global news mani Iranians will not be
satisfied if the government simply
scapegoats a minor military figure oh
you did
he says Iran has a diverse range of
views but many people in the country are
united in their outrage and the regime
is worried on Thursday Canada's foreign
affairs minister francois Philippe
champagne will be joined here at Canada
House in London by his counterparts from
Afghanistan Sweden the UK and Ukraine
The ministers will aim to devise a
strategy on the best way to find out
exactly how and why this tragedy
occurred and how to provide justice for
the victims families
Donna Redman Shannon in London thanks
some kind of political shake-up is
underway in Russia all of it managed by
President Vladimir Putin the Prime
Minister Dmitry Medvedev and his entire
cabinet have resigned
a surprise move came after Putin
proposed a series of constitutional
changes it's not clear how it will all
play out but it's thought Putin who
controls everything in Russia is setting
the stage to stay in power beyond 2024
when his term is up he said today the
changes revealed in an address to the
nation would be good for Russia Putin
has held the reins of power as president
or prime minister ever since Boris
Yeltsin resigned in 1999 and in
Washington the next step is taking place
in the impeachment of President Donald
Trump
inside the US Capitol the articles of
impeachment have been hand-delivered
from the house to the Senate that paves
the way for a trial to begin on Tuesday
with senators serving as jurors House
Democrats appointed seven impeachment
managers to argue their case that
President Trump should be removed from
office over his efforts to pressure
Ukraine to dig up dirt on his political
rivals ahead of the 2020 election the
emphasis is making the strongest
possible case to protect and defend our
Constitution to seek the truth for the
American people we already know at the
end of this Trump won't be removed from
office though the Republicans have a
majority in the Senate who will prevent
that but there could be some surprises
along the way including who shows up to
testify there's outrage tonight after
evidence emerged president Trump's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani may have carried
out surveillance of the former US
ambassador to Ukraine Murray yovanovich
Jovanovic who was known for her efforts
to combat corruption in Ukraine was
fired by President Trump last May
allegedly because she was a roadblock in
Trump's desire to have Ukraine
investigate Democrat Joe Biden and his
son hunter yovanovich testified in the
House impeachment hearings that she was
the victim of what she called a smear
campaign and that Giuliani tried to
undermine her standing in Keith when
snow brings cities to a standstill
coming up the mess and misery NBC's
Lower Mainland Lassa heart-stopping
moment on a Canadian highway and who's
behind it
you
heavy snow and wind flashing parts of
southern BC leading to dangerous driving
conditions also making public transit a
nightmare with snow and freezing
temperatures causing commuter train
doors to malfunction forcing staff to
use creative tools to clear the way for
hundreds of passengers lined up in the
cold some for hours it's not going at
all long no way to 50 minutes and they
close the sky train station down send
everybody home grow up in Winnipeg boys
you'll know as snow days all about I'm
from New York so this is nothing this
may not seem like a lot of snow for the
rest of Canada but here in southern BC
many communities just aren't used to
this kind of weather resources to deal
with the snow are limited and the many
hills and mountain roads make conditions
even more difficult
while riders and drivers are dreading
more delays it's a dream come true for
students with entire school districts
shutting down whether on foot ski or
toboggan people are finding new ways to
get around and clear out roads streets
and footpaths as homeless advocates are
trying to keep people safe from the
elements we have activated our warming
centers we have four sites open tonight
more snow is on the way and BC drivers
especially those who don't have proper
tires are being urged to avoid the roads
altogether if they can Neetu gotcha
Global News a deep freeze has set in
across a huge swath of Western Canada
tonight an Arctic blasts and
temperatures plummeting way below
freezing
extreme cold warnings are in effect for
Northern Ontario Manitoba Saskatchewan
all of Alberta and most of BC the worst
is Alberta temperatures there is dropped
as low as minus 48 degrees with the wind
chill it feels more like minus 50
Edmonton woke up to minus 37 Calgary
minus 32 the extreme cold conditions are
expected to last throughout the week and
people are being told to limit the time
they spend outdoors
ahead Megan makes a special visit to
Vancouver will tell you where she went
you are watching global national much
has been said and written about Harry
and Megan wanting to step back as
full-time Royals and yesterday Megan
surprised everyone by making a low-key
visit to one of Canada's poorest
neighbourhoods she met with staff at a
Women's Center in Vancouver's Downtown
Eastside Robyn Gill reveals what
happened Vancouver's Downtown Eastside
is notorious for its homelessness and
rampant drug use this is where the
duchess of sussex decided to pay a
spontaneous low-key visit to a Women's
Center Megan had a lot of questions
about how the center helps the
marginalized unfortunately often when
there is attention on this community or
on our organization it's not for a good
reason it's for a sad reason the Duchess
was on a research mission and stayed
away from talk of her royal position but
her Sussex status will have sway in
Canada and as a sign she's moving on
from the discord with the royal family
it instantly signals that this is not
about petty family divisions but this is
really about being able to focus on work
concentrate on work that is found to be
meaningful
both the Duke and Duchess now have an
opportunity to be global ambassadors
based in this country according to this
royal observer there is a golden
opportunity here to have them as as
these sort of diplomats the Supreme
diplomats for the Commonwealth as
headquartered in Canada instead of over
in the United Kingdom in 2016 in another
royal visit Kate and William came to the
same Vancouver neighborhood and met with
young mothers struggling with substance
abuse despite leaving London behind for
now Megan is continuing the royal
tradition of helping charities in Canada
the focus still I think for the royal
family is to work very hard and to work
in contributing to society as much as
they can for the Women's Centre it's not
unwanted attention she did shine alight
and she did bring attention to the
Women's Centre and you know what we do
to support women every day because in
this part of the world the situation is
desperate
Robin Gill globe
News Vancouver next Canada's sweet tooth
new citizen that is Whitney Houston
she's been inducted into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame for the first time
since 2001 seven musicians are being
honored posthumously
they include notorious b.i.g Depeche
Mode and the California rock group The
Doobie Brothers well it's been over four
years since Canada took in 25,000
refugees from Syria Tarek Haddad was
among them
his family had a business making
chocolates in Syria but when their
factory was bombed they were forced to
flee they lost everything and when they
arrived in Nova Scotia putting down
roots meant reopening that business
today had that accomplished another
dream he became a Canadian citizen
Ross Lord reports Tarek Haddad even
among dozens of grateful immigrants
being sworn in as new Canadians Terrica
dad's journey is remarkable I think this
country has given me an opportunity a
chance and I'm so proud to see so many
people reflecting on our story as a
success for immigration in this country
these moments were unimaginable five
years ago when his family's Chocolate
Factory in Syria was destroyed by a bomb
forcing him and his family to live in a
refugee camp the Chocolate Company he
started in Nova Scotia called peace buy
chocolate got a shout out from Prime
Minister Trudeau at a United Nations
conference ever since business has grown
Haddad's workforce has doubled from 10
to 20 and his chocolates have found
buyers all over the world he's selling a
product by selling a message that unity
among different cultures and different
countries is possible I am a proud
ambassador and you see this is my honor
that I will have it framed in my heart
and framed on my wall in my room to
remember every day how proud I am
federal government suggests haddad is an
example of how immigration is supposed
to work noting he's among 70,000 Syrian
refugees who've entered Canada other
members of the Haddad family are working
to attain their Canadian citizenship in
coming months
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
such a great story and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm donor
Friesen tonight's your Canada is gran
datang Nova Scotia we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye
[Music]